the National Transportation Safety Board
blasted another federal regulator for
not doing enough to get unsafe bus and
truck drivers off the road now this was
an investigation into a 2016 bus crash
in California four people died in this
accident and 20 others were hurt
investigators found that the driver was
severely sleep-deprived they also
concluded that the Federal Motor Carrier
Safety Administration could have acted
on safety issues which may have
prevented this crash Kris Van Cleave is
in Arlington Virginia with more on this
story Chris good morning well good
morning FMCSA is essentially in agency
without a lot of leadership right now it
hasn't had a full-time administrator
since January the Acting Administrator
retired earlier this month and the
appointee to take over the agency still
hasn't been confirmed by Congress the
NTSB is basically saying someone over
there needs to get to work a deadly
accident was horrifying a signpost tore
through much of the buses passenger
cabin just after 3:00 a.m. it was every
type of injury you could think on this
the NTSB found the bus company had
demonstrated its repeated lack of
compliance but was allowed to keep
operating shortly before the crash it
passed an inspection by the Federal
Motor Carrier Safety Administration or
FMCSA despite a virtual laundry list of
issues the NTSB also found drivers
worked too many hours and falsified
reports it listed FMCSA s lack of
oversight as a contributing factor in
the crash
are there unsafe drivers on the road
today and are signs being missed I think
so NTSB chair Robert Sun Walt was there
enough evidence with their existing
rules to have taken action to prevent
this crash well we think so we think
that that they should have done a better
job with knowing what was going on with
this particular carrier our 2016
investigation raised questions about
FMCSA s oversight and its medical
reporting requirements we found a
voluntary reporting system with drivers
failing to report dangerous medical
conditions the agency declined to talk
on camera but in a statement said it
will review the NTS b--'s findings
adding safety will always be
it's highest-priority the agency did
eventually shut down the bus operator
more than two months after the deadly
crash
I think they need better regulations to
enforce what they're doing and they need
to do a better job of doing what their
regulations call for a DoD official was
quick to point out that this accident
occurred during the previous
administration the NTSB notes earlier
this year
FMCSA abandoned new regulations on a
safety rating system and sleep apnea
Nora alright Chris thank you so much